in esports there exists a certain set of
thunderous unthinkable plays which are
so iconic that they've etched their
instigators
into history final minute this was the
scoreline of game three
cloud nine unable to take it but squishy
now
daily he puts it through he's been going
for this stuff
all season and he pulls it off here in
the most clutch moment
garrett is going to be waiting hiko
charges in doesn't check
oh my god inhuman reactions
armada not giving him anything
that could be it
now if you're one of the lucky few
who've made such a play
it can become your legacy the thing that
defines you
see double smoke's in the same place
they're simple just jumping casually
into the side he's gonna fall down and
get right down
right what is this simple are you
serious what is that you can't do that
simple that's not allowed
this is not fpl this is a major but if
you're the player being dunked on
it can be tough to live down i recognize
it yeah
yeah i get simple yeah yeah
here's the thing though for the vast
majority of professionals
taking the ass whooping of a lifetime
isn't that big of a deal
sure there's a certain embarrassment
that comes with being turned into a
clippable highlight in front of
thousands of onlookers
but typically top tier competitors can
shrug these instances off and move on
with their lives
that is unless you're you ryu sang-wook
the unfortunate recipient of the
cleanest oh look at the classic
and costliest beatdown in league of
legends history baker
what was that so how exactly did a
single outplay both derail ryu's career
and launch it into infamy and in what
weird way has it kind of come full
circle there's a joke in korea that says
um read the ice every five seconds it
means like
if someone watches the faker versus
through zed clip every five seconds
okay so if you are not familiar with the
absolutely
awe-inspiring faker versus ryu outplay
it's safe to say that you're not a true
fan of the score esports
alongside old reliable and coldzera's
flying
rng circus faker vs ryu is sitting
pretty in the holy trifecta of [ __ ]
stomps we've shoehorned into basically
every video we've ever made
and with good reason in spite of all
your memeing
you idiots eat that [ __ ] up now everyone
knows what league's single greatest
dumpstering did for faker
since it pretty much signaled his coming
out to the western world
it cemented him as the brazen bowl-cut
divinity he
is and forever will be what they might
not know or
even think about is what it did to ryu
now
aside from having mastered the art of
poker face ryu is known for being an
advocate of mid-game battle naps
and for his strong opinions on lane
matchups i mean i'm glad he's really
respectful but
there are definitely times where i'm
sitting there like hey ryu why don't we
do you know this and this with mid
and he just looks at me and goes bad
prior to his run-in with the cleanse and
the moves
ryu was actually regarded as one of
south korea's greatest
talents and one of the most promising
mid laners in the world
alongside eventual superstars score and
cacao
ryu helped the fledgling kt rolster
bullets roster secure a top three finish
in their first season of champions
now it was around this time that korean
league of legends became
very competitive several stacked rosters
had entered the fray
including the new faker driven skt the
result was that ryu
and kt bombed out of quarter-finals
during the spring
champions tournament they're going for
it this is a bit risky they managed to
take out
mafa and they're getting it in the nexus
turret
here comes insect trying to distract
them trying to give his team
time to come up but the nexus is going
down as ozone don't be impossible
the nexus dies despite this sobering
setback
katie entered champion summer 2013 with
something to prove
and in the playoffs they did just that
by clawing their way past
cj blaze and convincingly ripping
through cj frost
on route to the grand finals meeting kt
there was
sk telecom who had cruised through their
side of the bracket
and fans were excited by the prospect of
seeing two of korea's best mid laners
going head to head
up to that moment and and after that
moment too to a certain extent like
ryu is known as like one of the best uh
mid laners in
league of legends like he he really
really was he was just a very dominant
mid laner both in terms of like
uh how he played out team fights but
also you know being in lane and he was
like a 1v1 you know master really i
think
i think a lot of people are very excited
about ryu um i think the the question on
a lot of people's minds
especially you know going into some of
those early matches against faker was
like not
israel as good as faker the question was
is faker as good as ryu
and in the first two games of the series
ryu and the bullets were poised to
answer that question
emphatically now fondue's flash is back
up against me
and there it is the flash crescendo they
do get ryu but here we go now
insect coming in to try to engage impact
from the top with that slicing mousetrap
a huge three-man shockwave
piglet on the outside doing a lot of
damage
and oh my gosh has sk held no despite
another double kill
from piglet it's just not quite enough a
triple kill
for score a quadrant kill and here we go
insect coming from the top
a nice crow storm again insect picks up
the kill immediately faker
wrapped up with the exhaust didn't get
anything done in the meantime
impact finally tracks down score gets
that one but a double kill for ryu
cacao getting chased impact the last man
standing
can he finish a fight a triple kill for
impact oh but insect
is the one to finish it all in ace skt
was on the brink of being swept
in embarrassing fashion but of course
the highly annoyed unkillable demon king
wasn't going to let that happen and skt
responded by taking the next
two games in the series now sadly for kt
fans the deciding game 5
wasn't very close but right as rolster
were on their last legs
ryu made a decision that would haunt him
for the rest of his career
i'm like even though i only have a mat
on the floor i think he's in the bed oh
baker may be in trouble your death arc
tries to clean it up for ryu oh look at
the glass look at the moves
faker what was that baker with a huge
play the qss i can't take my messiah
that's right faker clapped our boy so
hard that it gave way to one of league's
oldest and most elemental memes
the infamous ryu face
it was a face of like resignation right
he looked uh
a bit dejected you know but that was
only that's in that's in terms of like
ryu dejection
because yeah that wasn't like a turning
point in the match or anything
like that like they were so far ahead
they were just gonna steamroll them
completely but
to lose and then individually get like
outplayed there's just like a layer of
get me out of this game the rest of
course is history
skt went on to crush rolster yet again
in the regional finals
win worlds and initiate the greatest
dynasty in league of legends history
but things didn't work out as well for
ryu he became a source of derision among
the community and
shortly after the humbling incident his
performance began to suffer
by 2014 the bullets were pretty much in
the dumpster and it was starting to feel
as if ryu's career momentum would never
recover
following his viral encounter with
league's four-eyed deity
looking for a fresh start ryu ventured
to europe but his association with the
famous play had become
inescapable even there ryu in that mid
lane everybody who knows this man
if you don't go google faker versus
ryu zed zed crazy crazy jewel epic stuff
eventually the nomadic korean mid laner
found a home with h2k in 2015
and it was with that roster that he
reminded everyone that he was still
capable of creating highlights of his
own half of the games they play
but it it seldom gets two more
rounds saw it he's gone all in chaos
storm had a gravity stunt
ryu has he
[Applause]
still keeping time on this baron freddy
magenta gets the big one that's
a shutdown though for ryu cause singh
pops them on soon all of a sudden that's
the two of the back
two kills the baron assist and ryu
chasing down and raided and candy panda
how about it a serious amount of damage
on him it's forgiven moves forward fox
trying to sustain up yarning now there's
the exhaust not forgiven order
comes in and picks up fox there's a
shutdown however by n rated as he takes
out a one-night down forgive it
watching forward gets another picks up
casing
and there's the death mark forgiven
spawn reusable
he doesn't care about the mvp but in
spite of ryu's strong performances which
helped the team to qualify for worlds
that year
it still felt like he was only going to
be remembered as the dude who got
clapped by the greatest
to ever play the game no matter how
humble he was
or how hard he worked he couldn't shake
his demon and
man did he want to i mean i still
remember like when he would go back to
korea between like spring and summer for
example
like he would go back and they would you
know still reference that play like ryu
is still dying every minute somewhere
and they would show him on camera like
in the studio watching the lck games
years later so i i don't think his uh
you know coming to europe or in a was an
escape because
there was no escape ryu dies every
minute right but ryuu wouldn't have to
wait too long for his shot at redemption
as fate conspired to see the two mid
laners cross
paths again during the group stage of
worlds 2015.
this was ryu's chance to exact sweet
revenge
good they didn't take off
but things didn't go as ryu had hoped
even though he managed to slay his
adversary once
gets caught by the cocoon glacial fishes
flash
gets faker empress divides splits up but
ryu
kills faker faker ended up having the
last laugh
yet again next is turret number one will
be dropping at the 31st
minute number two will follow shortly
thereafter
and skt are on the board 1-0 in the
group stages
that game he played so weird he didn't
leave mid lane at all and usually this
is a big roaming player right ryu's
always everywhere he likes to influence
a lot
this is the first time i saw ryu like
want to stay in lane
and like actively try to only kill the
mid laner
i mean skt they went on to win worlds
like that was a really low percentage
we'd ever win that match it was very
very difficult
but to see ryu play that way where it
was like it felt very overt like i want
to kill faker
uh and he did get a couple kills on him
so
i'm sure he enjoyed that a lot but it
was funny to see
him be normally very stoic and you know
non-emotional and then when he finally
plays faker he's
all out trying to murder him in game in
spite of the disappointing end to 2015
h2k returned in 2016 stronger and made
it back to worlds
and thanks to a fantastic run in groups
and a somewhat lucky quarter-final draw
they found themselves in the semi-finals
ryu was one series away from meeting
faker in yet another grand final but
unfortunately samsung galaxy had other
plans
the nexus turret is falling under
pressure cube left untouched
h2k they cannot leave their fountain h2k
they will be going home and there's
nothing that they can do
a 3-0 sweep of europe's h2k
will send samsung galaxy to the world
final finally the time had come for ryu
to accept his fate
to do what every adored accomplished and
altogether
washed korean superstar must do once he
finds that he has nowhere left to turn
play in a suit
[Music]
one he made a promising transition to
hundred thieves to once again play for
his former coach
prolly but after a poor showing at
worlds 2018
he retired to become an assistant coach
after that
he joined the academy roster got moved
back onto the full roster for a
single split and is now for all intents
and purposes
teamless so what's the moral of ryu's
ostensibly sad
story well in spite of all his
misfortunes ryu never
actually let his fabled run-in with
faker define him
in fact he let it fuel him
[Music]
on
[Music]
ryu might not have gone on to have the
tremendous level of success or fame that
his mid lane rival did but his
tragic contribution to one of league's
most influential moments
undeniably shaped the game into what it
is today
i think that moment did a lot for
esports in general
and at the in the moment especially
korean esports in terms of getting
english-speaking fans to tune in a lot
more and watch and really appreciate it
but also just
you know the world in general where um
you know people kind of realize
that the the human drama that exists in
these competitions is just as valid as
as a any other sports competition in
2019
riot paid further homage to the play's
significance by adding the galaxy
slayer's zed skin
which included a modified version of
doa's iconic call as a voice line
look at the skill look at the moves zed
what was that look at the end of the day
everybody ends
up with egg on their face at some point
even faker
khan steps forward that's the ulti down
now gq can look to turn the fight caught
huge
healing coming back on the back end of
that ultimate faker now steps forward
faker now gets taken out
and you could see the frustration his
hands are shaking he realizes
the consequences of his actions does one
instance of failure mean that he's
washed in spite of what the
cesspool of tsm worshipping casuals that
is the league subreddit would have you
believe
no faker the goat the unkillable demon
king
the mid lane god whatever you want to
call him
is just a man he makes mistakes too not
unlike ryu i think that's the mark of a
true professional and a true you know
competitor that you realize that you can
be at the very bottom you can have those
moments you know where where
things could not possibly go worse but
at the end of the day it's just one
match and a bad match you know doesn't
make for a bad season a bad season
doesn't make for bad
you know year and a bad year doesn't
make for a bad career you can
continue to you know improve and you
continue to be as good of a player as
you can be in your sport and i think ryu
is a good example of you know not
allowing those
really down moments to sort of like uh
ruin things and
that ultimately is what the ryu face
represents
the fact that it's okay to fail for as
much as everyone
ridicules what happened to ryu they'd be
lying if they said they couldn't relate
to it
whether you're vying for a championship
or simply trying to rack up some elo
you're going to fall short the important
thing is not to dwell on it
but to look forward to the next matchup
and
to his credit ryu always has
who wins it on 1v1 i mean
yo i edited the video the most iconic
uh esports moment the faker versus rio i
play and i've watched it
hundreds of times i still don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on you know
what's funny everyone always says
make that joke about dota about like oh
no one knows what's happening in dota
team fights dude
league of legends man it's all the same
[ __ ] like
is it a dash or is it a flash is it a
[ __ ] everyone is just these slicy slashy
[ __ ]
like it everything looks the same to me
like in dota the problem is there's too
much going on in the screen like these
crazy abilities and i agree but in
league there's too little like i don't
know it's just it's just like
it looks like power stone it's like a
little third-person fighting game like
there's just too much two like it's all
just dashy slashy [ __ ]
like i don't i don't understand what the
[ __ ] is going on in any of it all of
them league is just so cringe dude
[ __ ] olive league is so [ __ ]
cringe if i see if i see one more time
the world's panel has gone on [ __ ]
cool down
i'm gonna lose my mind